[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
vendée globe 2016 des yvelinois et
rébellion tandis de la motte et oui
burton sont toujours en course pour le
tour du monde en solitaire et sans
escale nous ferons le point sur leur
classement dans cette émission football
les clayes-sous-bois ont réalisé
l'exploit de ce 5e tour de la coupe
gambardella la coupe de france des moins
de 19 ans les élus n'en sortit clichy
sur seine retour sur cette performance
quelques minutes rugby montigny le
bretonneux prend la tête du classement
de 1re série après sa victoire à
domicile contre corbeil-essonnes plus
d'informations à suivre gros plan à
présent sur les principaux résultats du
week end
le vendée globe 2016 a débuté le
dimanche 6 novembre à 13h02 29 skippers
ont pris le départ pour ce tour du monde
en solitaire et sans escale depuis les
sables d'olonne parmi les marins de l'ex
amant retrouve à 3 illinois tanguy de
lamotte le versailles et éric bellion et
le robot litas à louis burton retour sur
ces premiers jours de course le montage
est signée à exhaler jamais
les 3 heavy mois sont toujours en course
pour ce vendée globe 2016 les
versaillais tanguy de lamotte et éric
bellion et le rambolitains louis burton
sont au large de l'afrique après être
parti le 6 novembre dernier des sables
d'olonne pour ce tour du monde en
solitaire et sans escale classé la
neuvième place mercredi dernier tanguy
de lamotte avait le sourire au début de
l'aventuré à bord d'initiative coeur
vient de passer la zone interdite du dst
du cap finistère et on à hisser le
gennaker avec les dauphins
bon après midi et bonne soirée à tous
c'est parti pour le tour du maurier
mais le ver seuil et a vite déchanté son
imoca initiative coeur a été victime
d'une avarie sur la tête de masse ce
dimanche au large du cap-vert évinois dû
réparer lui-même les dégâts en train de
pêcher la voile et surtout la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'elle est là voilà les
plus dans la quille
ça c'est bon ça voilà
la vraie d'abord elle est plus dans la
quille
au
bien commun
l'impression de déjà vu cette partie de
pêche là
au pointage de 15 heures ce lundi 14
novembre tanguy de lamotte occupe la 20e
place du classement de son côté éric
bellion sur comme un seul homme est
installé à la 25e position pour son
premier vendée globe le skipper garde le
moral là depuis trois jours j'ai eu les
problèmes que qu'il terrorisait plus
avant de partir vers ce vendée globe
j'ai eu grand gennaker
il s'est déroulé dans vincent 9 ans
alors que la falaise
hier soir j'ai fait un de nuit j'espère
un départ à l'abattée avec le gennaker à
contre couché sur l'eau toutes les
sauces et vraiment c'est ce qui faisait
le plus peur est en fait ce que je veux
vous dire c'est que
ça sert à rien d'avoir peur en fait on a
peur d'avoir peur
ça s'est bien passé j'ai trouvé les
solutions
le troisième il vinoy louis burton qui
avait dû abandonner en 2012 suite à une
collision avec un chalutier est pour
l'instant la 14e place sur son imoca
bureau vallée pour tenir le skipper
communique avec sa famille le bateau va
vite moi je suis en pleine forme vous me
manquez beaucoup beaucoup je n'arrête
pas de regarder des photos et je vais
mettre une petite chanson pour qu'on
danse tous ensemble vous trois à la
maison et puis moi dans le bateau
allez on va dehors mais à mort
[Musique]
cette huitième édition du vendée globe
est toujours dominé par le britannique
alex thomson sur hugo boss les premiers
ne sont pas attendu aux sables d'olonne
avant deux mois et demi
aussi ont réalisé une performance rare
en football les clayes-sous-bois qui
évolue en deuxième division de district
ont réussi à se qualifier pour le 6e
tour de la coupe gambardella en
s'imposant contre clichy sur seine sur
le score de 3 buts à 2 puis 3 buts à 1
cette victoire permet à l'équipe
d'écrire l'une des plus belles pages de
son histoire à nicolas landry a pour les
images un exploit historique le club des
clayes-sous-bois participera au 6e tour
de la coupe gambardella la coupe de
france des moins de 19 ans avec les
siens qui évolue en deuxième division de
district ont réussi à faire tomber
clichy sur seine au stade beltramini une
équipe qui évolue deux divisions au
dessus des yvelinois le score 3 busan on
est bien rentré dedans on a dominé en
première période on a mis le but qu'il
fallait le mettre ensuite en deuxième
c'était plus dur ils sont revenus il
voulait revenir dans le match mon a tenu
avec le troisième but en fin de match
ont naturellement qu on se tuera les uns
pour les autres c'est comme ça je coupe
le match en 2 première mi temps et gagne
2 0 au deuxième mi-temps et non
satisfaits en mettant leur dernier but
qui fait important des habitants et qui
nous donne un score total de 3 ans donc
entièrement satisfait de cette équipe
qui veut et qui a envie d'aller le plus
loin possible et continuer l'aventuré
comme toujours grâce à cette victoire
les clients sont devenus le petit poucet
français de l'épreuve ils peuvent
rencontrer au prochain tour une équipe
située en dehors de la région ile de
france le tirage au sort sera effectué
ce mercredi 16 novembre au siège de la
fédération française à paris les
clayes-sous-bois ne veulent pas encore
se projeter sur leurs futurs adversaires
n'allaient plus haut possible à l'eau
puis on peut surprendre du plaisir
d'aller le plus haut possible un centre
de formation ce serait bien aussi peu
importe ils veulent voyager donc ça peut
être long et qu'on peut aller jouer loin
ce serait ça leur fera plaisir je te
reprendre des journées au travail la
salle avis on va le faire pour le 6e
tour de la coupe gambardella est
programmée le week end des 3 et 4
décembre
du rugby à présent
montigny-le-bretonneux a réalisé la
bonne opération de ce week-end en
première série lésigny montrent un
premier remporté sur leur terrain le
choc entre le deuxième corbeil-essonnes
sur le score de 29 à 7 avec quatre
essais à la clé une victoire qui leur
permet d'engranger une sixième victoire
en six matches disputés de prendre la
tête avec cinq points d'avancé sur leur
adversaire du jour on écoute
l'entraîneur de l'équipe segal muriel
était au micro de nicolas d'ombré ont
fait un match sérieux sérieuse dans
l'application des consignes sérieux dans
l'engagement ça défensivement on était
peut-être un peu trop impatient de
vouloir enchaîner temps de jeu mais par
rapport à la semaine dernière où on
avait été un peu insipide on est
contents puisque corbeil était invaincu
on était aussi on gagne avec le bonus
offensif donc et du mieux mais il faut
continuer à travailler parce que la
semaine prochaine va senlis un club pas
facile on joue également ce week-end en
fédérale 3 de rugby plaisir n'a pas fait
de détail contre caen les joueurs de
jean miss se sont imposés 75 à 0 sur
leur terrain au classement pas de
changement dans la poule de la division
est toujours dominé par ris orangis les
plaisirs roi occupe toujours la deuxième
place du championnat du ballon ovale on
passe au ballon de handball rien ne va
plus pour l'équipe senior a féminine de
montigny le bretonneux les i montaigne
se sont inclinés 24 à 21 ce week-end
contre le handball-club lannoy à
l'extérieur leur cinquième défaite de la
saison six matches un résultat qui
plonge les saint-quentinoises à la
dernière place du classement de
nationale 2 on écoute la réaction du
président du club christophe reading
début de saison de l'équipe première
féminine commence pas forcément sur des
chapeaux de roue mais cela en fait peut
s'expliquer par plusieurs choses il
n'est jamais évident de rebondir après
une descente de n1 sur nationale 2 car
en fait
on a des contraintes liées à une
reconstruction de l'équipe plus 80% de
l'équipe a été reconstruite ont fait pas
des miracles en quelques jours où il
faut quand même un certain temps il faut
du travail aussi bien sûr sur du
qualitatif et d'intensifs mais avant
tout c'est arrivé à créer un collectif
en prend à présent la direction du
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines c'est désormais officiel la
première édition de la révolution sont
impliqués d'annuler et de reporter à
l'année prochaine par les organisateurs
la compétition devait opposer les
pistards et les meilleurs routiers du
monde du 18 au 19 novembre dans la
structure c'est le deuxième événement de
grande ampleur annulé à la dernière
minute au vélodrome après le gala de
boxe annulé en juin 2015 on écoute le
responsable marketing et communication
même et bruce se goldstein alors on
parle plutôt d'un report et non d'une
annulation
faut vraiment le souligner pour la
simple et bonne raison que certains
formats événementiels novateur pour la
france et qu'on a besoin d'un peu plus
de temps pour assurer le succès de cette
manifestation
donc on parle bien d'un report et non
d'une annulation c'est une déception
pour le vélodrome déception non parce
qu'encore une fois on maintient un
événement donc plutôt sur l'année 2017
et on veut vraiment s'assurer du succès
de la manifestation donc c'est aussi
pour cette raison qu'on a choisi de le
mettre son l'année suivante et pourquoi
justement avoir voulu le le déplacer il
n'y avait peut-être pas assez de places
vendues alors oui tout à fait en toute
transparence
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
choisi de déplacer la manifestation
encore une fois on a validé l'événement
assez tardivement là on l'a acté au mois
de juillet on a débuté la communication
à la fin de l'été donc début septembre
et pour une manifestation de cette
ampleur comme unité de deux mois et demi
avant c'est un peu court
on a plusieurs facteurs qui peuvent
l'expliquer 1 c'est un nouvel événement
de levée rom est encore assez récent
donc on a besoin de temps véritablement
pour en inscrire le la manifestation
dans l'esprit des gens c'est un deuxième
couac une vraiment pour le vélodrome
après les championnats de boxe qui
devait être organisée en 2015 qui avait
été déjà annulé est ce que c'est un
nouveau couac où vous prenez comme voilà
un manque d'expérience peut-être sur ses
premières années non en fait vraiment
pas du tout en quoi qu ai je maquille
pas le discours on est vraiment
transparent dans ce qu'on veut dans nos
réponses
premier facteur si on arrive à
intéresser des organisateurs
outre-manche donc notamment en
angleterre c'est qu'il ya une véritable
explication l'explication elle est allé
derrière vous je trouve que le lieu
attire
et c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle
les révolutions series devront se tenir
en france pour animer justement un
équipement de cet emploi donc c'est
vraiment pas en quoi quand c est ce qu
on prend notre temps pour pour assurer
la jauge et puis être faire carton plein
pour cette première édition et l'a
répété dans le temps et comment va se
passer du coup le remboursement alors
toutes les personnes feront rembourser
intégralement de leur billet
c'est ticketmaster
donc le retour de vente qui va s'occuper
de cette opération est de surcroît pour
l'édition 2010 est ces personnes
bénéficieront également d'une relique
un mot de golf la nouvelle est tombée à
la semaine dernière un groupe
d'investisseurs chinois devrait entrer
dans la dotation de l'open de france de
golf qui est organisée tous les ans au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'entreprise
h1n1 aurait décidé d'investir dans le
golfe en france en vue de la ryder cup
2018 qui je vous le rappelle sont
organisées en septembre 2018 à
guyancourt la dotation de l'open de
france devrait passer de 3,5 à 7
millions d'euros à des l'édition 2010
est en passe maintenant notre rubrique
agenda
du rugby pour commencer et cet agenda en
division honneur les versailles et qui
sont descendus cette année dans cette
division reçoivent la troisième du
championnat vitry ce dimanche à 15
heures les bleus devront l'emporter pour
remonter au classement ça ne va pas fort
pour versailles en ce début de saison
l'équipe est pour l'instant dans les
profondeurs du classement verra-t-on à
versailles à réaction ce week-end
réponse au stade de porchefontaine
dimanche si vous n'aimez pas le rugby il
ya également en du football à versailles
l'équipe senior de football de la ville
jouera ce dimanche à 15 heures au stade
mont boron les versaillais reçoivent
dans leur enceinte issy les moulineaux
les hippies noah seront ultra favori de
la rencontre leader de la division avec
six victoires et deux nuls en huit
matches ils ont déjà sept points
d'avancé sur le deuxième et plus de 13
points sur issy les moulineaux la montée
semble se dessiner pour les joueurs de
la cité royale et puis a toujours en
football on jouera également dans le
championnat excellence
montigny-le-bretonneux septième du
classement reçoit sur son terrain le
troisième versailles 2 à l'occasion de
la 8e journée du championnat et victoire
désigné mon teint pourrait leur
permettre de remonter dans le top 5 du
classement en cas de défaite l'équipe se
retrouverait en danger si vous voulez
les encourager le match est programmé au
stade de la couderc ce dimanche à 15
heures c'est la fin de six sept huit
sports merci d'avoir suivi on se
retrouve lundi prochain pour un nouveau
magazine d'ici là passez une excellente
semaine sportive
[Musique]